all right hi everyone happy Monday
today is the last lecture before we move
into reinforcement learning topics
as a couple course reminders tomorrow at
5 PM we have a tutorial on value-based
RL this should be kind of a refresher
for people who are a little bit less
familiar with reinforcement learning and
cover the kinds of things that you kind
of like reinforcement learning Basics
that you would see in classes like cs221
or cs229
um on Wednesday the project proposal is
due like I mentioned before we're
grading these very lightly the goal is
really primarily for your own benefit to
give you feedback on the proposal and
then and so forth
and then Monday next week uh homework 2
is due and then homework three will be
released
any logistical questions
cool uh so for today
uh we're gonna be talking about Bayesian
metal learning and first we'll talk
about why it can be useful to be vision
and what that sort of thinking allows us
to do
we'll talk about Bayesian metal learning
approaches including Black Box
approaches and optimization-based
approaches and then we'll also talk
about how we can evaluate Bayesian meta
learners
the goals for the lecture are to be able
to understand the interpretation of meta
learning as inference in Bayesian
graphical models and also to understand
techniques for representing uncertainty
over parameters and over predictions
um similar to the previous lecture this
is an active area of research and so
um there might be more questions and
answers and it will also this lecture
will also cover some of the most
advanced content of the course and so I
definitely would encourage you to ask
questions
especially in like the later half of the
lecture which becomes kind of the more
advanced part
um yeah and then we can discuss and also
if you don't understand something
um yeah it's not your fault it's most
likely my fault
cool so um to recap from last week or
from yeah from last week we talked about
a perspective on metal learning which is
this computation graph perspective where
for Black Box approaches we view metal
learning as kind of learning from data
with a black box neural network we view
optimization-based approaches as methods
that embed an optimization into the
metal learning process to quickly learn
from support sets and we also talked
about non-parametric methods which learn
embeddings such that you can do things
like nearest neighbors to solve future
learning problems
um we also talked about different
algorithmic properties of metal learning
algorithms that can be useful
so for example we talked about
expressive power which is useful to be
able to represent a wide range of
learning procedures we also talked about
consistency which means that our learner
is guaranteed to kind of improve an
expectation when you give it more and
more data
and these properties are important
then we also briefly mentioned
uncertainty awareness which is
essentially the ability to reason about
ambiguity during the learning process
and this can be useful for things like
Active Learning getting calibrated on
certainty estimates which is important
in safety critical applications and also
in reinforcement learning domains and it
also gives us some more principled
approaches and this is essentially this
kind of last part here is what we're
going to be really focusing on in this
lecture
great so
why be Bayesian
um
in multitasking metal learning we talked
a lot about how we want training and
test time to try to match so that you're
actually training for the ability to
solve
to solve the test tasks
and the tusks also need to share some
structure
and we always talked about structure as
uh kind of more colloquially I guess
than really is anything formal and it's
if you try to think more formally it's
not actually obvious what structure
should mean
and one thing that I think one way I
think that's nice to look at this is
actually from the Bayesian perspective
which is uh to say that structure means
that there's a statistical dependence
between the tasks on some shared latent
information
and I'll refer to that that shared
latent information as Theta
and in particular you can think about
this graphical model right here
where you have your true task specific
parameters Phi I
um there's some shared information
between all of the tasks that's
represented as Theta
and then the data for each task
including the trading data and the test
data is ultimately well specifically
that the labels are ultimately a
function of the task specific parameters
Phi I and the inputs X
um and here circles are referring to
things that are observed during
um
that are observed during the process
um why test has like a partially shaded
thing to indicate that it's observed
during the meditating process but not
observed in metatest time
um and so note that we don't directly
observe Theta or Phi we only observe the
data
cool and so this is an interesting way
to look at things I think because if you
then condition on the shared information
then we can first note that the task
parameters will become independent
conditioned on that that shared
information
um and otherwise the task parameters are
not independent if you don't condition
all that information
this also means that as a result you
will have a lower entropy the
distribution over
Phi has a lower entropy if you condition
on Theta and this means that essentially
Theta is giving you information about
the um about the
about how to infer the underlying
parameters compared to if you're just
trying to learn the task specific
parameters completely from scratch
cool so uh I thought exercise for you
uh which is that if you can identify
Theta via meta learning
when should learning Phi I be faster
than learning from scratch
so you're saying the mutual information
between Theta and Phi I is not zero
yeah so this means that
um the essentially the tasks are not
completely independent of one another
and if they're not independent of one
another then you should be able to learn
faster than learning from scratch
and this is essentially exactly what
what I mean by they share some structure
right
do you have anything to add
okay another thought exercise
um what if uh the entropy of Phi I given
Theta is zero
yeah
yeah exactly so um in this case if you
could fully determine Phi I from Theta
this means that the tasks are
essentially
um not Netflix is it like they share
everything basically you could figure
out how to solve the tasks from Theta
alone without actually using data for
example
cool so this is um this is essentially
the like
the way to think about shared structure
and this kind of these different
Criterion can allow you to think about
things like memorization which we talked
about last lecture which is happens
exactly in the second condition it can
also help you think about whether or not
you're going to get efficiency like
better efficiency compared to learning
from scratch for this first thought
exercise another scenario where this can
come up is that
um so you already built in structure
into your Optimizer or into your
function approximator or something like
that then in those cases
um identifying Theta won't necessarily
be faster than learning from scratch
because you already built that structure
into your optimization
cool um and so we can think about a few
examples for this graphical model so
um say that you are kind of in this
sinusoid regression case where different
tasks correspond to sinusoid functions
with different phase and different
amplitude
um
does anyone have any thoughts on what
the information in Theta would contain
if your different tasks correspond to
these different sinusoid curves
yeah foreign
shape the periodicity of the function
and so forth so basically
Theta corresponds to like the family of
sinusoid functions that underlie the the
task family
um simply everything but the phase and
amplitude which it has to infer from the
data
another example is
um you could apply meta learning to
multi-language machine translation where
you want to quickly adapt to low
resource languages
um in this case you're trying to adapt
to a new language
with data and so in this case what does
Theta what what information does data
contain
yes
[Music]
like things that are General to language
to multiple different languages like
that might things like the basic kind of
grammar or syntax some some languages
have different syntax so you need to
only encode the things that are the the
most General
cool so yeah essentially Theta will
correspond to the kind of the family of
all all the different languages and the
things that's shared among those
languages rather than things that are
different
um great and you should note that in in
both of these examples Theta is going to
be narrower than the space of all
possible functions uh this is really
important if it's the space of all
possible functions then you're not going
to gain anything compared to learning
from scratch
great
um and then one other one last thought
exercise is uh what if you're
doing meta learning and you don't have a
lot of tasks and particularly you don't
have a lot of like data for a lot of
different tasks in order to meditate
from
what will happen in that case
and what will Theta contain
yep
yeah so essentially theta's go not in a
case like this Theta is going to be
narrower it's going to have it's going
to overfit and it might represent a
smaller family of tasks than you
ultimately want it to represent
um so it'll eventually have this form of
like meta overfitting to the family of
training functions rather than the
entire family of tasks that you
can great
um
so
that's the kind of gist of uh the kind
of high level structure of Bayesian
metal learning algorithms or not visual
learning algorithms but kind of the
perspective of meddlering Within These
Bayesian graphical models
um
now a lot of the algorithms that we've
talked about so far are going to give
you a single set of task specific
parameters so they're essentially going
to return we can think of as a point
estimate of this this distribution
um
in many cases this might be fine so in
your homework for example you've been
inferring parameters and it has been
getting hopefully uh reasonable accuracy
on the problems
in One cases might it be a problem to
only recover a single
parameter yeah
what do you mean
yeah okay
um
yeah so essentially if you have
uncertainty I guess first note that this
is a distribution over parameters rather
than labels but essentially if you have
a multimodal distribution over possible
functions that could explain the data in
some cases that might be okay because
um these may be uh especially in
unimodal cases like there's probably
like one correct answer but in cases
where you have more multimodal
distributions and there's like clearly
like multiple viable solutions to the
problem
um representing that uncertainty can
probably be quite important
um cool so as a few examples uh in some
cases few shot learning problems might
be ambiguous and this might lead to
multiple Solutions including kind of
multimodal distributions over five even
when you have the prior data
um as an example of this uh say you
wanted to learn a classifier and you had
these 10 examples so it's a few shot
learning problem
and these are your positives and these
are your negatives
uh in this case
uh if you look at these there's actually
a lot of things that could explain what
this classifier is trying to predict so
for example everyone on the left is
wearing a hat and everyone on the right
isn't wearing a hat
um also everyone on the left is smiling
and everyone on the right is not smiling
um and
also the at least according to the
labels they think that everyone on the
left is Young and everyone on the right
is not young I'm not sure if that's
accurate but there are essentially these
multiple underlying attributes here
and as a result this means that when it
comes time to get a classifier for these
things uh you're not sure what you
should be classifying on then ultimately
if you get someone that's smiling and
wearing a hat and is not young for
example it's just inherently ambiguous
what the correct answer is
as another example maybe you have
someone that's not smiling wearing a hot
and young and is also ambiguous
and so these in these in these problems
it would be nice to be able to represent
a distribution over classifiers that for
example cover different combinations of
these attributes so that you can
ultimately
um
ultimately do something about reducing
that ambiguity like asking a user to um
to help you reduce that ambiguity
and so in particular it'd be nice if we
could be able to generate hypotheses
about the underlying function and be
able to essentially sample from the
distribution of Phi I given Theta and
that would allow us to sample
classifiers where one classifier might
only pay attention to Smiling one might
only pay attention to wearing a hat
maybe you would pay attention to a pair
of these attributes and so forth
I mean if we could generate these
hypotheses then this will be first
important for safety critical few shot
learning problems like Medical Imaging
it's helpful to know if it's certain
about a particular outcome or if it's
uncertain about a particular outcome
um it could also be useful for learning
to actively learn so that if you have
some data set of unlabeled examples it
can tell you give me a label for this
and that will help me reduce my
uncertainty
um
and we won't really talk about today but
there are actually some papers that
explicitly look at look at Active
Learning with meta learning that are
listed there if you're interested in
learning more
and then lastly it can also be useful
for learning how to explore in meta RL
where you want to try to
find seek out parts of the state space
seek out parts of your world that help
you reduce the ambiguity
okay any questions on the setup or the
graphical model that we talked about
before
um
before we go into the algorithms
okay
so we're going to talk about both Black
Box approaches and optimization based
approaches and we'll start with the
black box approaches
and um I guess in particular that this
first approach will be General to all of
the different
methods
and what we can do is we can have this F
function
output the parameters of a distribution
over the label y test
um
and in classification problems you're
actually already doing this when you
train with cross-entropy loss because
you have kind of loaded you'll have
probabilities for each of the classes
um and you you do this uh you can do
this in classification you can also do
it in regression where instead of
outputting probabilities for each class
you output the parameters of a gaussian
distribution like the mean and the
variance or the parameters of a gaussian
mixture
um so yeah it can be probability values
in a categorical distribution mean
invariance of gaussian means variances
and mixture weights of a mixture of
gaussians
um you could also do kind of an auto
regressive distribution as well for
sequential labels
and then
once you kind of choose the the way to
parametrize your distribution over the
labels you can just optimize with
maximum likelihood
and when you do cross entropy you're
actually already doing this and you can
also do that with these distributions as
well
um so I guess in some ways uh yours have
sort of already implemented kind of v0
of evasion meta learning algorithm
um this approach is very simple uh you
can combine it with all the different
methods that we showed before
however it has some shortcomings
and in particular you're only reasoning
about uncertainty of the label rather
than uncertainty over the underlying
function
so in particular you're thinking about P
of Y rather than P of Phi I
and this means that you can't determine
how kind of uncertainty across different
data points is related to one another
and for example in the classification we
saw before you can't sample like a
classifier for young and a classifier
for wearing a hat
um also uh the distributions over why
that you can represent easily are
somewhat limited we saw kind of these
like a gaussian or a mixture of
gaussians um and you ultimately might
want to represent more expressive
distributions
um and then it's also worth mentioning
that things like standard cross entropy
loss tend to produce somewhat poorly
calibrated uncertainty estimates
typically when you train with standard
cross entropy the uncertainty or the the
probabilities of the outputs
don't actually reflect the probability
that the classifier is correct for that
class or for that example
so
um now with others like I think this is
the final thought exercise for you which
is that
um
here we're doing maximum likelihood
training over the labels why
can you do this same sort of approach
except do maximum likelihood training
for the parameters Phi instead
foreign
does anyone have thoughts on this
so for these approaches what we did is
we had we're outputting a distribution
over Y and then we do maximum likelihood
trading for
um with like across entropy loss or
something like that to get that
distribution
kind of
approximately some kind of distribution
time and then
yeah so you're saying that it should be
possible if you can sample different
fives
and where do those files come from
you'd have to learn the five for the
data that you're given do you have
something that read similar with this
topic
sample different data sets for different
fives computer system
yeah so I think that essentially what
you're getting at is that for each of
the tasks that you have
um you want to essentially somehow get
labels for five by training a model on
that data set and then once you have
those files for each of those data sets
then you can use kind of supervised
learning onto those files
now the tricky part that comes up here
which you might have realized is that
um
I mean I guess there's a few things like
first you don't get these five labels
for free like the Y's come for free in
your data set
um
and so you have to somehow like be able
to get samples from like five for each
of your tasks you can you could train
separate networks to do that although
you may not get like full coverage over
Phi which is actually ends up being
quite difficult in practice
um and then the second problem is that
you would then be doing supervised
learning on Phi which may not actually
represent the
um
may not actually uh like the loss
function over five may not actually
represent the loss function that you
care about and errors and matching five
may not translate into errors into y
um May translate into like much worse
errors into y for example
and so kind of the short answer for this
thought exercise is that it's extremely
difficult to do maximum likelihood
directly over Phi uh because you can't
directly observe samples from Phi
whereas if we go back to the graphical
model we saw before we do actually
directly observe samples for the labels
why
and so a lot of Asian metal learning
algorithms will kind of amount to trying
to
get better algorithms for getting
distributions over Phi
um and in particular I guess I'll just
quickly go back to the
um back to the graphical model that we
saw before
and so as you can note here you can see
that at least the Y train is observed
directly whereas Phi is not observed
directly and that's what makes it
challenging
and as kind of a hint towards what we'll
see
next is that you could essentially think
of Phi is a latent variable in the sense
that it's not directly observed
and this means that a lot of the
techniques that we have for using for
dealing with latent variables like
variational autoencoders and other
things can be applied for learning
distributions over Phi
cool
so um as we
kind of started to think about how we
can actually represent PFI given Theta
I'll just briefly overview some of the
tools that we have
in our tour disposal in order to solve
this problem
this is a very kind of broad one-slide
overview if you want a more kind of
thorough treatment of this cs236
provides more more details on a lot of
these approaches
and they're really the goal of these
tools is to be able to represent
distributions with neural networks
including distributions over latent
variables rather than just observed
variables
um so the first tool that we have is
latent variable models and variational
inference this will be one of the
biggest tools that we'll use I mean we
had the the tutorial on this
um last week
the way that these algorithms work very
roughly is to try to approximate the
likelihood of your latent variable using
a lower bound like an estimated lower
bound on that likelihood
and for example the we have like the the
variational Autumn coder which thinks
about a latent variable Z and an
observed variable X
um and in reality those don't have to
just be x and z you can kind of rename
those variables and this the whole
framework still applies
another class of approaches is Bayesian
ensembles
these methods essentially try to
um
represent samples from your distribution
as different particles
and basically the way that they work is
you train separate models on different
bootstraps of your data so you resample
your data in different ways you train a
model on each resampled data set uh and
then each of those resample data sets
often will essentially correspond to a
kind of different samples from your your
distribution
another class of approaches is Bayesian
neural networks these approaches to try
to actually learn an explicit
distribution over the space of neural
network parameters oftentimes it's a
gaussian distribution because that's one
of the things that's easiest to deal
with although sometimes it's somewhat
unsatisfying because gaussian
distributions are limited in what they
can represent
um there's also a class of approaches
based on normalizing flows
these approaches are pretty cool they
learn an invertible function that maps
from some latent distribution to a data
distribution
and for example you can kind of
translate between a nice gaussian
distribution to a more complex
distribution such as these um I don't
know what it's called
these kind of hemisphere distributions
um then lastly there's also energy-based
models and Gans which essentially try to
estimate a normalized version of the
density and this essentially corresponds
to trying to push down the data and push
up everything else
yeah
so uh we're really going to focus on the
the first two classes of classes of
approaches for solving problems uh in
Invasion meta learning but I figured
that I would briefly mention these
because they're also cool approaches and
could also be used potentially to
develop Bayesian metal learning
algorithms
um so the the yeah these last three
approaches could be useful When
developing new methods
okay
um so let's start with variational
inference and the first class of
approaches
and in particular uh one of the things
that you would have seen in the tutorial
if you watched it is that we can think
about this graphical model right here
which is a very kind of simplified
latent variable model where we have some
latent variable Z and some observed
variable X
and
the if we care about maximizing the
likelihood of x
we can derive a lower bound on this
likelihood which corresponds to the
equation on the right which is
essentially estimating the
log probability of x and z when sampling
under the expectation of this inference
Network Q Plus the entropy of
um of that inference Network
this can also be written as this form
right here which if you've trained
variational autoencoders you might be a
little bit more familiar with where
essentially you uh sample from your your
generative model maximize the likelihood
of those generations and then
minimize the kale Divergence between
your inferred latent variable and the
prior
in this case p is representing the model
it's essentially representing this
generative process of the data
and you would represent P of x given Z
as a neural network that takes its input
a latent variable or a value of a latent
variable and Maps it to a
generated data point such as an image
and then the distribution over your
latent variable is typically represented
as just a standard gaussian distribution
so this is like the two components of
your model which you can use to generate
data
that follows your data distribution and
then Q of Z given X is representing your
inference Network it's also referred to
as the variational distribution
um
and it represents the
um kind of the likelihood of different
latent variables for a given
X
and then typically we'll refer to model
parameters as Theta and variational
parameters as Phi
um this will be
this is a bit of a kind of overload of
notation compared to the meta learning
terminology that we've referred to
before
um and all
when we kind of use these we'll try to
be careful about those
um careful about that uh fortunately it
doesn't uh it doesn't shouldn't end up
being too much of a problem
okay
um so
now if you look at this objective
typically you try to maximize these
lower bounds on the likelihood so that
you are ultimately Max like trying to do
something similar to maximizing the
likelihood of your data
um now there's a problem if you try to
maximize these objectives which is that
you have this sampling distribution Q of
Z given X that you're sampling from and
you need to differentiate through that
sampling distribution in order to
optimize in order to appropriately
optimize your inference Network
so essentially you need to compute the
derivative of the expectation of Q with
respect to Q
and the the nice thing about using a
gaussian for Q is that you can use
What's called the reparametrization
trick which is that for gaussian random
variable you can represent it as the
mean plus the variance times some noise
and the right hand side of this equation
even though you're actually sampling the
right hand side is actually fully
differentiable into me into the mean and
variance
um that this allows you to essentially
back propagate into that sampling
distribution and optimize the objective
end to end
Okay so
uh this is kind of some background
content and is what was
kind of a very brief overview of what
was covered in the tutorial
now we'd like to be able to use these
tools for meta learning and really a
really kind of core conceptual leap that
we'll be making is that
this variational autoencoder is looking
at a latent variable Z and an observed
variable X but it really doesn't need to
be Z and X I can be these the same kind
of tool in the same lower bound can
apply to graphical models with other
kinds of latent variables such as when
we make the latent variable Phi and and
The observed variable the data
cool so the way that we can do this is
we have our data
um and we'd like to
um say for for Black Box methods we like
to be able to have a neural network that
outputs the distribution over Phi given
our training data
um and so uh and then ultimately this
file will be used to make predictions
for new data points when we sample from
that distribution
um and so in the standard Bae we had
this observed variable X and the latent
variable Z and we were able to derive
the elbow
in um and P was the model that was
represented by a neural network Q is at
inference Network
now in the middle learning case
we have an observed variable which is
our data
and we have a latent variable which
corresponds to the task specific
parameters Phi I
and what we can do is we can essentially
derive an elbow that just replaces Z
with Phi and replaces x with d
uh and we get an objective that looks
like this
and then we have a couple choices here
so
you'll note in this objective is that
we're kind of maximizing the likelihood
of the data given Phi this is actually
fairly standard
um this next approach is we're actually
going to have an inference Network
that's going to try to infer Phi
and in this variation lower bound your
choice of Q can actually condition on
anything that you want
um
and what we can do is we can have this Q
condition on our training data
so essentially our inference network is
going to be inferring the task specific
parameters given our training data
and so this equation on the top right is
the exact same as this equation here
except now we've changed our variational
family to condition on the training data
um and this is uh
somewhat analogous to the Elbow here
except we made a particular choice which
is that instead of conditioning on all
of our data for Phi we're only going to
condition on the training data
and this is pretty useful because if we
then want to infer our our latent
variables are our task specific
parameters from training data we can do
so even from a small training data set
rather than from a larger data set for
that task
okay
um and then one last thing that will
change
is that instead of what I mean kind of
modeling the distribution of data given
Phi we'll have this correspond to our
test examples
and making this explicit difference
between train and test allows us to
explicitly kind of optimize for
generalization
and so essentially what this corresponds
to is
um really the almost the same thing as
black box metal learning except we now
have this kale Divergence term that
encourages the inferred parameters to be
to be close to The Scouting prior over a
test specific parameters
great um then you might also be
wondering what about the meta parameters
Theta
um these meta parameters data they can
essentially be
kind of folded into your your inference
uh your inference Network they could
also be a part of your prior as well
um essentially these meta parameters are
going to be what you're going to be
using to
um to infer your task specific
parameters
um if you want you could also condition
on Theta here and that would correspond
to something like the uh like other
parts it doesn't directly output Phi but
also incorporates other parameters like
an RNN
yeah
um
[Music]
yeah
so it's a good question so the question
is uh should Q here be conditioned on
the data so if you match this this bound
directly it would be conditioned on the
data
for your variational distribution it's
typical in variational Auto encoders to
condition your inference Network on X
but in reality uh Q can actually
condition on whatever you want it to X
is simply the thing that gives it
information about Z as you'll see on the
top right we're actually going to choose
the condition Q on the training data we
could also choose to condition it on all
of the data for the task
um we're actually gonna we're gonna
choose the training data so that at test
time we can infer the task specific
parameters given our training data which
is given a small training data set which
will be quite convenient because then
when we do few shot learning at test
time we can infer a distribution over a
Phi given the the few trading examples
does that make sense
cool
so to recap we essentially took the
variational lower bound
um
viewed the data as our observed variable
viewed Phi as our latent variable our
inference network is going to be kind of
doing the uh the process of adapt of
adaptation essentially of learning or
task specific parameters and the process
of optimizing this lower bound will be
uh be the process of meta learning
essentially
um
our kind of final objective for
completeness looks something like this
um
and the essentially what this is doing
is it's now just uh for for Simplicity
of notation I dropped all the all the
sub I's on everything now if we look at
this full equation we have an
expectation over our cost distribution
and then we're actually inferring
parameters by I given training data set
for test eye
um
yeah great question so are you asking
why aren't we maximizing over the thigh
as well so you'll notice here that we're
only doing a maximization over Theta and
here Phi corresponds to the latent
variables and we're doing uh we're like
inferring those latent variables given
the training data set and just like as
we saw in the meta learning process
we're only optimizing over Theta here
because Phi is more like a latent
variable more like activations and less
and less like a underlying
um
like an underlying parameter this is
potentially where the
the overloading notation that I
mentioned before can get a little bit
confusing is if I or Phi is no longer
representing the parameters of the
inference Network like in standard vaes
it's representing the the latent
variable
and so in vaes for example we don't
optimize over Z because it's a Latin
variable
s
yeah exactly so you can like in a sense
that this is like a variational auto
enclosure you could sort of view this as
an autoencoder that
um or the latent variable are these
parameters and the thing that you're
inferring that you're Auto encoding is
the data
um
so in this case actually Q is the neural
network that's taking in the data and
outputting the five eyes
and P is the the neural network that is
um
that is then taking those five eyes and
making it's pretty few labels from those
eyes and so in the terminology that
we're using before Q corresponds to F
and P corresponds to G
cool so here's the equation again
um this is kind of the uh
the first approach that we'll see that
can actually represent a distribution
over task specific parameters
and this is kind of a black box variant
of the approach
um and this alleviates kind of the the
shortcomings that we saw with trying to
do something like maximum likelihood
um
this means that it can actually now
represent non-gaussian distributions
over the tests over the labels because
it'll represent a gaussian distribution
over Phi and then predict the labels
from that uh
from samples from that distribution
um and like the important bit is it can
produce a distribution over functions
rather than just producing a
distribution over labels
there are some downsides with this
approach this means that it can only
represent gaussian distributions over
Phi I
uh and this can be unsatisfying if we
want to be able to represent more
diverse distributions over functions
although if you do have a very deep
Network gaussian distributions can
actually
they do actually end up being somewhat
expressive
um yeah and that's the that's the only
con of this approach
cool um so this is uh the I think that
if you were to do a Bayesian metal
learning algorithm with a black box
approach I think that this is a pretty
good one to use
I'm also
I'm not sure if there's any particular
paper that goes into this but if you're
interested in kind of reading more about
an approach that looks like this we can
we can also send some paper references
great um so now let's talk about some
optimization based approaches
so
one way to look at it
um
one way to look at kind of optimization
based approaches is actually through a
kind of somewhat crude Bayesian lens
and in particular
um
if you think about your graphical model
as this which is essentially the same as
the graphical model that we saw before
except we're now collapsing the um the
data sets into a single node
um
if we're trying to maximize our the
likelihood of our data given our meta
parameters Theta
we can essentially use what's called
empirical base
to write out that write out that
likelihood as
as the expression expression below which
is an integral over our task specific
parameters Phi representing the data
given Phi and Phi given Theta
and
what you can do is you can kind of
somewhat crudely approximate your uh
distribution of Phi I given Theta with
the map estimate the maximum apostory
estimate
and this is a
a reasonable approximation in cases
where you have a very peaky distribution
where the map estimate corresponds to a
large part of the distribution
and one thing that's kind of cool is
there's actually this connection between
grading descent and early stopping
AKA kind of what things like ma'am will
do and doing map inference uh in
particular under a gaussian prior with
the mean at the initial parameters
um and this you can actually show that
there's actually an exact relationship
between map inference and gradient
descent with early stopping in the
linear case
um in the non-linear case it's
approximate
and what this tells us is essentially
gives us a Bayesian interpretation of
the mammal algorithm
where you can view
um
enamel is optimizing under this kind of
approximation you can view mammals
optimizing for a a gaussian prior or the
mean of a gaussian prior
such that when you do map inference you
um
you get a a good solution
um so this is one cool interpretation of
that algorithm
that said with this interpretation we're
not able to sample parameters we're
using this map estimate to estimate the
distribution of Phi given Theta and as a
result it isn't kind of too useful from
a Bayesian perspective because we're
kind of getting rid of the thing that
makes it Bayesian which is that we're
using this point estimate rather than
the full distribution
and so in terms of developing an
algorithm we'd like to develop an
optimization-based algorithm that
actually kind of represents this
distribution over Phi given Theta
and so if we recall the the objective
that we saw before
Black Box methods
um one thing that you can kind of
remember is that Q
I mean the the inference Network Q it
can really be an arbitrary function
it can get a condition on a variety of
different things and it's just a
function that you learn
and so the first thing that you could
think about in terms of an
optimization-based algorithm is what if
we put a gradient operator into Q
um and
instead of using a black box method we
could essentially use a kind of
incorporate gradient descent into the
inference process for Q
um and then you get an algorithm called
um
amortized well an amortized page meta
learning algorithm where essentially Q
corresponds to running SGD on the mean
invariance of neural network weights
with respect to your trading data
and so in particular instead of having a
neural network that outputs Phi I
um given your training data you're going
to have
um
Theta is going to correspond to this
mean in this variance and this network
Qi it's no longer going to be a neural
network it's going to be a procedure
that runs gradient descent on those
parameters with respect to your training
data
any questions on how this works
now one thing you might be wondering is
like how can we run gradient descent on
a mean in a variance
um to do that we can essentially use the
same re-parametrization trick that we
saw before
where we essentially the neural network
weights we're going to be representing
this distribution over
Phi I and um
I'm going to get out a whiteboard marker
so
qfii sorry
qfii with respect to D train
and Theta Theta will correspond to this
mean and and variance
and then this function is going to be
running gradient descent on your mean
invariance
where you
um in particular the way that you run
grade sentence you'll use the
re-parametrization trick again where
you'll get
um
something like uh
uh a sample not sure how best to
represent this you can essentially
sample from this data by taking mu Plus
Sigma times Some Noise where Sigma is
drawn from a standard gaussian
distribution
and then
treat this as your the weights of your
neural network and back propagate into
these two values and you'll be
essentially running a gradient descent
with respect to mu and sigma where the
um
if I will be represented as or this
distribution over Phi I will be
represented as a gaussian distribution
with mean
kind of running out of notation to use
mean mu I and uh variance Sigma I and
this is going to be these two variables
are going to be equal to
um
running gradient descent on mu
with respect to your
training data
and running gradient descent on Sigma
with respect to your training data
and in particular this will be
um
when you run when you back propagate
your the loss of your training data into
mu and sigma this will be actually a
function of your current
um
over the kind of the parameters that are
represented by this
any questions on how this works
and you can see more confused faces than
knowledge so
yeah so once you get newer technology
great so the question is once you get mu
and sigma for five what do you do from
there great question so
um
this this distribution is represented by
mu I Sigma I which you get from running
gradient descent
um once you get that then you
um you can then kind of plug those in to
our objective from the Black Box metal
learning algorithm and do the same thing
that we did before where we're going to
be kind of optimizing for the the lower
bound on the the likelihood
um the and so
uh in particular the yeah you'll be
optimizing on the lower bound and then
at test time after you optimize for this
inference Network what you'll do is
you'll have your mu and sigma and you'll
have a trained data point you'll run
gradient descent and so you'll get each
of these parameters and then what you
can do is you can now sample Phi I from
this particular Junction distribution
and so
uh you'll then be able to sample
parameters from here and then that will
be those will represent like samples
from this will represent things like a
classifier based on age a classifier
based on hat and so forth
um
distribution and then what we do is we
refine it for a specific cost yeah
exactly so Phi and sigma are like a
shared Global mean invariance and then
we'll refine this mean invariance with
respect to a specific task with respect
to the training data and that will give
us a distribution over parameters for
that particular task
yeah exactly so this green descent
process is the inner loop and then
optimizing for these parameters
um with respect to that objective
corresponds to the Outer Loop
happens
thank you
very much I guess I guess things
yeah so
um the MU and sigma here this is this
kind of now corresponds to your Theta
and these are this is what you're
optimizing over in practice what this
will be is um
you'll essentially have twice the number
of meta parameters so before you just
had a like parameters in mammal you just
had like the initialization of a model
now you're going to have a mean of that
initialization and a variance and so
you're essentially going to have two
vectors that are the size of your
parameter vector rather than just one
something
so once we have this mean and the
variance will run gradient descent to
get the MU I and sigma I and then we'll
sample from this gaussian distribution
to get
um to get weights over a task specific
neural network
um
or
let's see like that
yeah so we had this diagram before with
mammal where like this is kind of your
final meta parameters and then this is
uh like Phi I hat and so forth and yeah
essentially the way that you can think
about this
is that now instead of having a single
point you're going to have these kind of
gaussian distributions
you'll have a gaussian distribution over
Theta and this will correspond to your
mu and sigma that reads this and then
now for each of these you'll also have
kind of your own gaussian distributions
over these parameters and this
corresponds to
um like Phi I and sigma I for each of
those tasks
um the and then ultimately this
distribution will cover the set of
parameters that work well for that task
um and so rather than having a single
put you'll have a distribution over
those parameters
does that answer your questions
so the updates will be with respect to
you'll be differentiating kind of
through the parameters of the gaussian
they won't necessarily have noise
foreign
actually
um this mu and sigma are the
um
are your your kind of parameters for
your task specific distribution and then
you'll have this KL term that encourages
these mutants like most to be close to a
standard unit gaussian
yeah exactly so in the in the Black Box
approach
um instead of having running gradient
descent we just had some function uh I
can't uh I'll refer to it as offered as
f um that takes his input uh
mu and sigma and D train and outputs
um
UI and sigma I you could essentially
think of it as just like a neural
network that takes it that produces
these these things
foreign
this doesn't need to be a gaussian and
so this can just be like Theta like you
don't really need it to be anything
um this is still restricted to be
gaussian because the
um because we're going to be
on the slides you see you have the
expectation with respect to q and you
also have this kale Divergence
to optimize through that expectation you
need to be gaussian to use the
re-parametrization trick and for the
kale it's also convenient for it to be
gaussian so that you can measure the
kale Divergence in clothes form
There's No Escape
yeah so so far we've only seen
approaches that have a gaussian
distribution over 5i
um on the next
few slides we'll see some non-gaussian
approaches as well
does the loss function for the inner
loop include a forward pass through
through p
yeah so this is going to involve a
forward pass through the network
parametrized by mu and sigma that
doesn't necessarily
uh
correspond to P per se
um because a p here is representing kind
of the model that
has parameters five but I guess in that
sense it like it is taking a forward
pass through a neural network that's
parameterized by
um by samples from Phi and sigma
cool
um so the benefit of this is unlike a
black box approach you're still running
gradient descent at test time
and you are actually so you're running
green test time and you are getting a
distribution over parameters by running
gradient descent on the mean and the
variance
the downside of course is that we're
still modeling Phi I as a gaussian
distribution we're just getting these
means and variances
um so can we model a non-gaussian
posterior is kind of the next key
question
um
so the first thing that we'll look at to
get a nine gaussian posterior is to use
ensembles
um and
ensembles are pretty nice in the sense
that it's actually very easy to get
non-fiction for series because
essentially uh different you're
representing different samples from your
posterior rather than the posterior
distribution itself
and so
they refer to this algorithm as kind of
an ensemble of or the kind of Base
version of an algorithm as an ensemble
of mammals or e-mammal and this will
essentially just train M independent
mammal models
uh yeah completely independently uh
here's an ensemble of mammals and
yeah it's also worth mentioning that you
can also use ensembles with black box
and non-parametric methods as well and
that will also give you
um
that will also give you essentially uh
non non-gaussian posteriors yeah
so how do you how do you ensure that
they're independent
um typically what you do is you kind of
frame it
so I guess there's a few different ways
to do it
um typically you'll definitely make the
initialization the random initialization
of the algorithm different you'll also
change the random seeds so that they see
batches in different orders
um
the kind of theory says that you should
also train it on different bootstraps of
your meta training data meaning that you
should resample your data and not use
all of it in practice and deep learning
people have found that you don't need to
do that you only need to
change the random initialization and the
seed that's used for the mini batching
and that will already
usually give you pretty good ensembles
so this can work pretty well uh
it won't work well with the Ensemble
members are too similar to one another
and this can sometimes happen
because you're I mean you're trading it
on the same data
and so there's alternative to the
approach that actually tries to make the
Ensemble more diverse and what it does
is it essentially has an ensemble but it
tries to push away the particles it
tries to push away the different
parameters
um from each other
and the way this works is you train an
ensemble and so J here is indexing the
different Ensemble elements and then you
have this repulsion term that's referred
to as this kind of Kernel between
um
between the parameters
and this will essentially try to make it
so that the Ensemble members are are
more different from one another
unfortunately getting good kernels in
weight space is difficult
um and so this can usually help to some
degree but
um but it doesn't always uh help that
much
um and here's an example of a more
diverse ensemble
um great and then you optimize of course
for the distribution of particles to
produce High likelihood
um
it's cool and so here's what the
likelihood term looks like
um which you
well yeah
cool um so the benefit of using
ensembles is that it's pretty simple it
tends to work quite well for non for
producing non-gaussian distributions
the downside is that you often need to
maintain different instances of your
model and so this can be computationally
expensive and also memory intensive as
well
um
one trick for getting away from this
downside is to have the Ensemble only
over the latter part of the network and
to have a shared backbone
um where you're essentially doing kind
of grading based inference on the last
layer only or the last few layers
um and this actually does
does help a lot with memory and
computation of course it often produces
less diverse ensembles but
um but it can be pretty helpful
it's cool
um
great and then I guess any questions
about ensembles
you have a longboarding
yeah the question is how often do we
need non-gaussian distributions
um
it's kind of hard to say
um I think that I mean in some ways I
think the objection to caption
distributions is more like philosophical
in some ways than than practical because
it seems just very inelegant to have
like a gaussian distributions over
parameters when your parameters are like
a neural network and they probably are
like probably the true distribution over
parameters is like very much not
gaussian
um
I think that uh there is actually a
paper that shows that if you have a
super deep Network
um gaussian distributions can represent
a lot and the intuition for that is that
if you have something gaussian at the
first layer then the neural network will
transform that distribution like the
later layers of the neural that will
transform it into something that is very
much not captioned
um and so
I think that it varies if you can use a
pretty if you're using a large Network
and you really care about performance
and practice then gaussian distributions
are probably fine
um
if you don't like captions and weight
space or or you have a smaller Network
that is probably less sufficient
[Music]
yeah so it doesn't have to be gaussian
like the main reasons why we're using
gaussian is because the repair position
trick and because the kale Divergence is
easier to
like you can measure in close form for
gaussians
um
the the first one is really the big one
is like how do you back propagate
through sampling
um you can approximate that for other
distributions as well although the
approximations are a little bit ugly
like there's
um and just like rather hacky in general
um like you can try to like do things
like the gumballs off Max and the
straight through estimator that try to
like
um back propagate through discrete
things there are some like
approximations that you can use for
mixture of gaussians as well
um but in general like back back
propagating through sampling for
non-gaussian distributions is uh rather
difficult
yeah so uh
I'll do this slide so
um we need to back propagate into this
queue so we have this expectation with
respect to Q we're going to estimate
this expectation by sampling from q and
then we need to back propagate into the
distribution that we're sampling from
um when you have uh when you have a
gaussian distribution
you can represent samples from that
gaussian distribution with this form
um where you sample you can essentially
kind of decouple the noise from the
parameters of the distribution where the
noise corresponds to
um
some standard gaussian distribution
and this because it has this very nice
form where it's decoupled you can
actually very nicely differentiate back
propagate into mu and sigma by sampling
this noise independently and then
running your gradient through with that
sample noise
and it's because it kind of decomposes
it into the noise and the distribution
parameters that makes it possible to
back propagate into
so the question was um in The Ensemble
based approaches how do you combine the
predictions into a single prediction
um the
the one of the most common approaches in
deep learning is to take the
distributions and like like do some sort
of like majority vote for example like
the thing that is the most likely you
could also average the distributions
um
we'll see in a couple slides how we can
use them for other things as well but
those are the two most common approaches
um yeah
to keep the moles independently even
when adapting at Medical side yeah
um yeah you do you typically do that
yeah exactly
um and so even when you're like adopting
a test angle if you kind of running
grading descent with respect to each of
the models independently and then you'll
get a final prediction
Empire
yeah so um if you want a lot of samples
from Phi you need an ensemble for every
single sample that you want um if you
want like 100 samples then you need 100
Ensemble elements and so
um yeah it can be pretty expensive
because you usually want M to be fairly
large and you're fairly limited by that
um in practice when people typically use
ensembles they use I don't know like
three to ten instances sometimes I mean
it really depends on the application but
that's kind of a ballpark estimate for
what people do
um
and if you have more compute you can do
more than that of course uh
yeah and that's that's one that's why
this Con like definitely is uh
potentially a big one
cool
um and then
the last method that we'll cover tries
to get a non-gaussian posterior over all
the parameters without requiring M model
instances
uh we don't have too much time so I'm
going to go through this somewhat
quickly because I also want to get
through the last part
um and in particular we're going to try
to sample parameter vectors with a
procedure that looks like hamiltonian
Monte Carlo
um
HMC it maybe sounds kind of complicated
but it the way that it works ends up
being fairly simple uh the way that it
works is you add noise
and then run gradient descent from from
the perturbed weights
and so in particular kind of intuitively
what we'd like to happen is say that
we're in the example that we saw before
we want to learn a prior such that if we
kind of randomly add noise and like
randomly kick the parameters
that will put us into different modes of
the distribution
and so if you have a very multimodal
distribution over weights such as like
classifiers corresponding to different
attributes
we want to be in a place where
if we kind of are at the top of this it
randomly kind of add noise and then run
grading descent
we'll get into one of the modes of that
distribution
and so if we add noise to Theta we'll
then push it in one of these directions
we'll then run gradient descent which
will then put us in the
um into producing a classifier that has
has those different attributes
ah so what's the intuition
um the way that it ends up working is we
have some
initial parameters Theta we're going to
be adding noise to this so we're going
to have a gaussian distribution we're
adding noise to it essentially
corresponds to sampling from that
gaussian
uh what were the mean is the starting
point
um so we're not no longer going to have
a single parameter Vector for that
initial parameters we're going to now
have
um a mean in the variance just like we
had the mean in the variance here
then we're going to sample a Phi and our
initial Phi by
um
ultimately by trying to represent this
distribution
we want to be able to represent this
distribution unfortunately this
distribution is uh like well the first
thing that we can mention is this
independent of X test it really only
depends on the training data
um ultimately this distribution
corresponds to this really nasty
integral
over our initial parameters Theta which
we don't want to
deal with
this is really intractable and so what
we're going to do is
um
say that we knew the distribution of Phi
given Theta X trade and Y train
and in particular
we're going to just set this
distribution to be gradient descent if
we have a sample of theta
then if you have this distribution then
then sampling is very easy because we
can sample Theta and then sample from
this
and it kind of transforms the graphical
model into something that looks like
like this where you sample from Theta
sample from Phi given Theta and the
training data
um and so the key idea is that we're
going to essentially estimate this
distribution as like the map estimate
like the crude approximation that we saw
before
um and we can
approximate this with map inference with
like a few steps of grain descent this
is very crude it's also very convenient
and
[Music]
essentially we're going to represent
this distribution as running one or a
few steps of gradient descent starting
from
the sample Theta
and then once you if you do this
approximation then you can again do
training with the same kind of a
procedure that we did before with
amortized variational inference
cool
um so then what ancestral sampling will
look like it's just the same as what we
saw before where we have our mean of our
gaussian distribution we add noise by
which corresponds to sampling from that
distribution
and then we run radiant descent from
that uh
from that samples uh
from that sample Theta to get to the
mode
um that was pretty quick but the
benefits of this is you can get a
non-gaussian posterior it's pretty
simple at test time because you just
sample and then run gradient descent and
you only have one model instance
although you do have you still are going
to have the double parameter Vector
rather than just one
um the downside is that it is a more
complex training procedure
cool so to summarize the methods that we
talked about
um version 0 just outputs the
distribution over y test which is quite
simple but doesn't allow us to reason
about the distribution over task
specific parameters
we also saw Black Box approaches which
use these latent variable models and
amortize variational inference
and this can represent non-gaussian
distributions over y
but it can only represent gaussian
distributions over Phi
um and then we also saw optimization
based approaches we saw how Amber did
basically take this approach and stick a
gradient step into Q which
um
which is simple uh but gives you only
gaussian distributions we saw ensembles
which are also simple and tend to work
well and give you non-gaussian
distributions but you have to maintain
at model instances
um and then we also saw hybrid inference
which gives you a non-gaussian posterior
and simple test time but it's a lot more
complex during Trading
cool um and then the last thing I'd like
to briefly go over is actually
evaluation of these metal Learners and
how you use them
um one thing you could do is try to use
standard benchmarks but the downside
here well the benefit is that they're
standardized their real images is a good
check that it didn't break anything but
the downsizer that oftentimes metrics
like accuracy don't actually evaluate
how well you're doing at representing
the distribution over parameters
um also some of the standard tasks may
not exhibit any ambiguity and so it may
be that you're good with a point
estimate you don't actually need a
distribution
and uncertainty may not be useful in the
data set
and so what are some better problems in
metrics
um ultimately it's going to care about
the problems that you care about
but
um here are a few examples so
one really simple example that's not
necessarily representative of a
practical problem but allows you to look
at ambiguity is these kinds of
regression and classification problems
where you give it a family of like
sinusoids and linear models you add
noise to the to the data points such
that in some of the examples like the
third example it's actually somewhat
ambiguous whether it's a sinusoid or a
linear curve and you can see whether the
model can capture these different modes
of the distribution
likewise you could give ambiguous
classification where you have like only
a single support example as represented
by the Blue Cross
or the blue plus sign and then you can
see that it can represent different
decision boundaries by sampling
different fives
uh including decision boundaries that
cover the true decision boundary which
is shown in Gray
um so this is one example
another example is you can look at
generation ambiguous generation tasks
where you get just like a single view of
an object and you want to be able to
generate other views of that object
um
and here's an example of a of a black
box Asian metal learning algorithm that
can kind of represent the ambiguity
whereas if you just use like a CV cvae
it doesn't represent the ambiguity well
and you can also look at the
reconstruction
another example is the ambiguous
classification task that we saw at the
very beginning of lecture where you need
to classify on a kind of unclear what
you need to classify on in terms of the
attributes and you could measure things
like accuracy as well as how well it
coverage it covers the different modes
of that distribution and also the
negative log likelihood of the
classifier
and then one last example is looking at
a reliability diagrams and calibration
error and what this is looking at is
looking at the confidence of the
classifier versus the accuracy of the
classifier on those data points and you
want this to be a perfect kind of
diagonal line and then kind of for
standard metal learning algorithms you
see that they aren't perfect they tend
to be overconfident they have more
confidence than their accuracy whereas
for evasion medical learning algorithms
they improve on this metric
um
cool
oh and then one last thing is uh also
looking at Active Learning so you can
use the the uncertainty to select data
points that you want labeled and pick
data points that's the most uncertain
about
um and you can use algorithms like this
to get better
performance with fewer additional data
points
so this I asked for one additional data
point two additional data points and so
forth and this allows it to reduce its
uncertainty faster and get a more
accurate predictor faster
um and you can likewise look at this in
terms of like mini image net accuracy
for example
cool
um we're out of time so I want to wrap
up there a couple reminders we'll be
starting reinforcement learning on
Wednesday
um and Carol will be giving the lecture
on Wednesday and if you're a little bit
Rusty on reinforcement learning I'd
encourage you to go to the tutorial